today I'm entering a bit of a
competition we're doing reddit Photoshop
battles this is actually how I learned
Photoshop I used to do tiny like
sub-community competition in like anime
forums
I remember how thrilling it was to
submit and have people vote on what you
made in Photoshop I thought that was so
fun
even if five people participated it was
still cool and that's what got me into
Photoshop so I thought I'll submit to
some of these I really liked the seal
one that was supposed to 11 hours ago
let's have a look at our competition
okay all right yeah all right I feel
like I can I can probably make something
out of this because it's already so
funny whenever I see chins I just want
to add more Chin's but then again
there's not that much to work with maybe
I can try and make the background a
little bigger see I mean already that
looks I didn't mean for that alright
we've made it bigger this means of
course we can add more chins nothing
like a good chin you know what I mean
you ever made something and then you
realise is complete garbage yeah oh man
that really did it didn't it
I'm shoulder I mean this calls for blush
cheeks okay alright I guess
uncomfortable is what we're going with
here I don't care if it's good it's
making me laugh
I want people that really truly question
their sexuality do you think we can add
a wig oh yeah oh yeah yes we can
yeah I'll freak a walrus I need
something higher resolution as well
okay okay okay girl keep talking all
right and let's lend shadows is really
what makes it come alive I think and
messing with light and stuff like then
on this photo we can see that the whites
are really popped I don't know yeah see
he's got the blend on the on the top and
we can't have that just trying to create
this yeah if we want to be like
attention to detail I guess the hair is
like hitting the water or something look
at that
sounded pretty good guess we should do
the lips as well it's got a little bit
of that Joker touch to it but you know I
like it
I really want to hit the sparkle on the
eye oh yeah that's dark in the roots all
that does a lot nice she has that kind
of faves you know it's a she
wish I want to play a fun more a bit
subtly like oh oh
standby oh yes I'm shading what you
think I am shading no I don't need you
to judge me for it okay all right I want
to do others as well so I'm just gonna
end that there and save it this is
actually the first time I pull something
like this so what that was to start this
is the result okay so it's uploaded I'm
sorry in advance all right let's move on
to the next one okay
a blue whale pooping what people talk
about plastic in the ocean but blue
whales poop come on dude that's
disgusting
alright that's nice that's garbage
what would I do would first cover up all
the poop so we got a fresh fresh ocean
nice and clean and then see what we can
do with this
[Music]
haha I've done it it's fun
I get to do typography I haven't done
that in so long I'll just go into the
air I guess guess it makes more sense
that it ends on the f' guess if you want
to be picky it should like fade over
time or something like he started riding
Epstein should be more faded as well I
realized but I think that's good for now
it makes me laugh so that's always good
original remake time to comment what are
the odds I can't wait to go back and
later in a few days to check what people
are saying that's gonna be my favorite
part all right let's pick two or three
more okay here's an easy one you just
change the TV I mean come on
okay there's a couple already yeah
alright this is extremely difficult I
mean this required immense amount of
skill and technique to really properly
pull off yeah not even worth posting I'm
not oh my god Novak Djokovic playing
tennis Jesus
no one's submitted all right it's my
turn gamer my time to shine
what I like about this is that you can
easily make it bigger very easily the
background is essentially blue anyway
there you go pretty well blended now we
can make his limbs now we can focus on
making his limbs gigantic without even
having to mask a lot of it leg you know
let's just get rid of the tennis racket
it looks funny if you don't have it I
[Music]
don't know what to do there's so many
things it's it funny to add this girl I
don't know will it be funny question
mark three two one go yeah that works
[Laughter]
that's funny that is actually
get that blue in fix the light at least
try and get the shadow I don't know how
I think that's pretty good to be honest
I liked it it was not what I was
planning to make but good exercise looks
pretty legit I'll take it I'll take one
I'll take it
I apologize I feel like that's always a
good way to start I can't wait to come
back in a couple days to see when no one
has commented on these come on this one
is obvious has anyone done it before is
lava
hey yo yo yo that really sold a deal hey
heyy alright I guess I'll do it
all this meme in the game it's about to
get new meaning it's gotta put him in
there basically hahaha that's great I
worked out better than I thought get the
text in cover up whatever the hell that
is okay cover up this bit fix the color
do the shading and there you have it
folks a new cat meme template you're
welcome I'll share it
it's an old meme but it still checks out
I'm posting too quickly Wow too fast for
this subreddit flooding in Venice that's
crazy yeah I have epic sense of humor
what a tragedy
r.i.p F's in the chat yeah I make myself
laugh I don't care I don't care you know
it's not only about technicality it's
about a great idea what deep tragedy get
it deep nine minutes alright I think
that's my time and this video there I
hope you guys enjoy let me know if this
is fun oh I'll be back in a second to
check out and see what people say of
course twelve seconds late go okay we
had time for one more one more gamers
the Tesla cyber truck there's definitely
a lot of things I can do with this I
feel like the obvious is just to put
some sort of low polygon yeah maybe I'll
put her inside
okay well that's incredibly lame yeah
that looks like [ __ ] okay I'll do
something else this will do I can work
with this just gonna draw his body in
really nice and tight that's right yeah
that looks very natural yes it's got to
do the same on this guy
well shadow it it will look at it'll
look fine gotta get that contrasting
color in it there it is yeah he's out in
the Sun he's doing stuff more natural we
of course have to make it very green
that looks good
I like that okay that's better I wonder
if it's worth adding some texture put it
on screen yeah that's not bad
I should add so he's like inhaler world
if I can find an image oh yeah this will
do it's got a blend in there you go
there you go all right now we're really
doing the details and there you have it
beautiful I like it a lot actually can't
migrate let's post this one as well
Elin sama I hope you like send alright
now it was time to wait a bit and we'll
see it what people think of our
beautiful art for the 28 a.m. okay it's
time to see the results I am so nervous
oh my god what if people don't like it
nein karma that's all what does that
mean I don't use reddit like I got an
actually post okay first one which is
the babe my magnum opus got five votes
that's it
are you kidding me five who won this
garbage are you kidding me this got six
uploads I got third thanks
fine you know what fine alright you know
it's like art people don't like when it
questions some their own things okay
there won't be P next one seven points
alright it's the blue whale pooping one
I got seven points top one got fourteen
are you kidding
why that's so [ __ ] I'm sorry this got
four up boats
this got four all right it's a
controversial subject but I'm pissed
dude like I don't mean to say that what
other people make is it's not garbage
I'm joking of course
I wouldn't call other people I got one
point for this this one got one point
are you kidding me dude it's got shadows
it's got color grading Oh apparently no
one else posted that means I won all
right we got one win gamer so we got one
win I'll take you I'll take it I'll take
it
it's an old meme but it still checks out
I got only two points what's the top 117
for this [ __ ]
I'm so mad I'm not even gonna pretend
I'm not man what the hell is this if
this whoever posts first wins all right
what about this one technicalities two
points yeah unfunny what about mine deep
tragedy hilarious there's dead pizzas in
the water that's funny
dead pizzas are funny laughs what the
hell is wrong with Reddit dude why can't
they not appreciate good creations why
can they not just upload my shitty posts
Elin sama no likes I am fuming I am
actually fuming this has been a complete
failure I will never do Photoshop
battles again I am actually angry delete
this video all right well I'm kidding I
actually had fun you know it's not about
the results it's about having fun right
right guys make me feel better
smash like on this video if you liked it
and I'll see you guys tomorrow bye bye
we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with a letter P can
you guess what it is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you